les pires raison de ruptures puisque
dans la pièce la perruche marié et
barbara jouent un couple au bord de la
rupture et du qu'on va jouer et que vous
les chroniqueurs et vos rupture alors il
ya des ruptures qui vont apparaître
à votre avis quelles ruptures correspond
à quelques chroniqueurs à ce qu'on peut
faire apparaître les rues g lagune
personnes par courrier mail ne l'a
jamais reçu alors par courrier ça à mon
avis ça doit être un télégramme ça doit
être isabelle morini-bosc non à la
larguer personnes isabelle combien a
alors pu être j'ai largué une personne
par pigeon voyageur mènera le reçu je me
suis fait larguer car mon conjoint avait
envie de me claquer quand je parle et ça
c'est à mon avis c'est maxime kenny lala
pour tout de suite
nos gars j'ai largué quelqu'un car il
était toujours d'accord avec moi alors
ça c'est vous non ouais quelqu'un par
contre je vais virer quelqu'un mais ça
commence à me faire chier je me suis
fait larguer par texto en pleine nuit
j'ai largué quelqu'un à cause de l'odeur
de ses pieds ça c'est assez sympa j'ai
largué la personne qui a piraté la
messagerie
je me suis fait larguer à cause du
monstre du loch ness ça c'est isabelle
morini-bosc je suis là non ça c'est jj
jim ici et je me suis fait larguer parce
que je n'avais pas si pas pris assez
poitrine isabelle c'est bon quoi donc
elle avait envie de vous claquez cause
sa dette diakhaté enchanté avec une
charmante rouquine très propre c'est
russell d'état
mais les coupes et une autre qu'on ait
du service d'hygiène mon père m en avait
plein de points en commun surtout la
bonne bouffe
elle avait une petite particularité ce
qu'elle me voulait m'embrasser que sur
la lèvre du bas elle me replacer à
chaque fois donc je l'embrassé que le
haut donc c'était un petit détail en
uruguay on s'entendait bien vous de
boîte et qui avec bref on sait on va
amener des crabes s est battue 17 voix
de demain n'en veut pas après demain je
peux pas après après demain je peux pas
et au final elle m'a envoyé un sms en
disant j'ai envie de te claquer quand tu
me parles je ne supporte pas ta voix
j'ai l'impression d'avoir à faire un
présentateur à longueur de journée ah
ouais bah je la comprends mais voilà
c'est ça et depuis on ne s'est jamais vu
il est reparti avec son ex non j'y suis
allé j'ai fait un effort j'ai été voir
la personne
ouais je l'installé tout il enlève ses
chaussures et là je me dis mais c'est
pas possible mais ça sent les poubelles
ça sent le fromage les poubelles non
c'est pas possible
donc je regarde quand même le match je
prends sur moi et le lendemain je
retourne le voir et appareils la même
chose il relève si je suis pas le mec en
fait il voulait absolument mais je suis
le kabyle plus des pieds c'est pas une
mais des bottes
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
tu le sais tu fais genre bosnie mais d
après ce qui annonce tout bas mais le
calme absolu manqué c'est comme les gars
qui peut de la gale et veulent
absolument vous dire des secrets nous
sommes en 1993 ne sont pas alors quoi
nous sommes nous sommes en 1993 en
écosse sur les bords du loch ness
je vis une amourette naissante avec
catherine que je viens de rencontrer et
catherine me dit nous sommes au début de
la relation j'aime l'histoire
j'ai dit mais c'est génial je vais
t'emmener chercher le monstre du loch
ness ça c'est de l'histoire
donc nous partons j'organise cinq jours
près d'inverness en écosse pour aller
chercher le monstre du loch ness
vous savez qu'il existe et personne n'a
encore trouvé et ouais c'est pas beau
tout un peuple dont tous les deux et il
pleut pendant trois jours le déluge
vous avez toujours beaucoup de chance et
moi j'ai arpenté le lac avec catherine
comme ça autour pour trouver le monde
nomade droit jouera les médias goudjil
c'est plus possible moi je partais pour
un petit séjour romantique se voit
jamais on poursuit ce [ __ ] de monde
j'en ai rien à faire n'était pas dans
ton et une super idée pourtant de vrais
dehors elle ses vitraux le vol qui était
pendant tout ce qui était bon
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je sois rocher je me suis fait larguer
parce que je n'avais pas à ce prix assez
poitrine isabelle alias et moi c'est moi
alors oui et non on vous sait madonna je
suis en alsace en commun et ça peut pas
être vrai tu en as plus que moi mais
vous alors vous la poitrine ah oui mais
ça ne nous était plus tôt
[Applaudissements]
j'avais 11 ans et j'avais un garçon qui
était qui m'aimait vraiment beaucoup
il me dit t'es pas joli pour l'instant
de toute crise est tout noir au 2010
était tout ce joli petit par et jolie
pour l'instant mais dans quatre cinq ans
tu sera parfaite
tu auras prix de la poitrine tu aura pas
d'effort visionnaire à 4,510 donc à 11
mars
non mais avec l alliance des rameaux max
[Applaudissements]
une très belle vue c'est barras et moi
s'il vous plaît j'avais un copain à
l'époque c'était alexis et dans la
coiffure mais porte comme coiffeur mais
c'est pas le taux de dossiers et la
coiffure mais par secteur la wii
maintenant oui mais en fait c'est lui
c'est avec 6 il avait une petite chienne
un cocker roux qui s'appelait madonna
adatia d'accord à chaque fois qu'on
était ensemble
madonna était père agressive avec moi
ouais un jour où on fait des choses à
l'étape de la couverture et à jour on
fait les choses un peu plus coquine sur
le canapé ah oui madonna ne m'en le
mollet
[Rires]
alors moi je m'énerve juni alexis
maintenant c'est madonna au moi et m'a
dit si tu m'aimes c'est un que c'est un
lot c'est madonna et moi
là il m'a dit il faut choisir célibat
écoute moi je ne choisis pas les deux
j'ai donc finalement il m'a dit moi je
garde ma de naïma largué non même il a
préféré la chaîne à vous il est préféré
madonna a à moi à écouter lire une bd
dire jaillir le sherbrookois et de quoi
le charme même mieux la cus
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]